dans une maison
la maîtresse de maison la ménagère
elle veut avoir un aspirateur d'avoir un
frigidaire
elle veut avoir une machine à laver
et même si c'est possible qu'on ait une
auto
ça c'est le mouvement
alors même temps elle veut pas que son
mari sans naim embauchés ne doute pas
que les gars on met les pieds sous la
table et que les fines en attend pas la
nuit chez land
et la ménagère veut le progrès mais ne
veut pas la pagaille
et bien c'est vrai aussi pour la france
il faut le progrès il faut pas la
pagaille le mouvement et l'ordre progrès
sans la pagaille vous
ou terriblement conservateur ces
conservateurs debout tant vous là
franchement le mouvement c'est là la
ménagère qui veut sa machine à laver
aujourd'hui je crois que les femmes
elles aspirent
à d'abord à ce que l'homme se s'occupe
des des lessives exactement comme elle
enfin bon non là je crois que on est
quand même on a encore progressé en
termes de libération et de mouvements et
de et de progressisme quand même
[Musique]